빌딩이 또 처음이신 분들이 대부분인데
그분들은
눈에 보이는 것만 보고 좀 이렇게
세부적으로 안 보는 경우가
대다수거든요
그러니까 더 큰 문제가 발생되기 전에
미리 좀 사전에 체크하는게 중요한 것
[음악]
같습니다네 제가 오늘은 bsm 케어에
박종구 과장님 모셨습니다 안녕하세요
일단 오늘 모신 이유가 그 최근에
저희가 그
빌딩을 한번 방문해서
현장 점검을 좀 했거든요
현장 점검하고 나서 이렇게 좀
문제점이라든지 이렇게 좀 개선
사항들이 좀 눈에 보이더라고요 이거를
조금 구독자 여러분들한테 좀
알려드리고자이
영상을 찍게 됐습니다
앞머리 코부터 천천히 다 하나하나
방문해서
점검사한 내용입니다 여기가 주차장
천장인데
등이 보면은 전체적으로 다 이상하게
나오거나 안 나오고 있습니다 사진으로
봐서 이렇게 조금 나오긴 하는데
눈에 좀 안 보일 정도로 그냥
꺼져있다고 생각하시면 됩니다 소방
관련된 그런 전선들인데 전체적으로
테이핑이 잘 안되있고
커버도 이런 식으로 빠져 있습니다
건물 내부에도 등이 안 나오는게 더
많고
계단 쪽도 전체적으로 다 안 나오고
문도 이렇게
고정도 제대로 안 되고
문이 힘이 없거든요 그리고 또
수리해야 되는 부분이고 여기가 6개월
정도 공실이었다고 했는데
에어컨이 켜져 있더라고요 그리고
밑에 보면 타이머가 연결되어 있긴
한데 이것도 제대로 세팅이 돼
있는지도 모르는게 대답합니다
엘리베이터 그 문이 열리고 다치는 거
내일이거든요
거기 보면은 이물질 같은게 또
가득했어가지고 나중에 가슴이나 고장의
원인이 됩니다
승강기 검사 필증을 붙여놔야 되는데
그것도 없네요 소방 발신기한데 아까
보셨던 전기테이핑이 불향인데 얘 같은
경우는 전선이 다 노출되어 있습니다
가정집에 쓰는 220볼트 전원을
사용하는 전선인데
처음 갔을 때 이런 상황이고
손을 잡아당겼을 때 그냥 막 빠질
정도의 고정이 안 돼서 나중에
철판이나 이런데 다음에 스파크하시거나
차단기 떨어지거나
재수 없으면 화제가 전기가 살아있는
것을
갖다 대면은 이렇게 소리가 나죠
신경 써서 제가 테이핑 해놓고
깔끔하게 해놓고 나왔습니다
친한 유도 등 보면은 불이 안 나오고
있고
원래는 정상적인 왼쪽처럼 이렇게 다
고정이 되어야 되는데 두 개가 따로
들어갔어 그리고
창문 쪽도
엄청 뻑뻑해서 아예 안 움직이더라고요
에어컨
필터 커버도 이렇게
빠져있었습니다
[음악]
제 기준에선 별 본 거긴 한데
다른 것도 더 있어요
지하에 오수랑 그런 걸 다 담는
집수장이거든요
원래는 다른 사람들은 여기 사다리
타고 내려올 생각을 안 하는데 저는
주말에 가서 궁금해서 한번 봤어요
여기는 그나마 삽다리가 좀 많이
낮아요
차를 보관하는 공간인데
구석에 보시면 이렇게 배수로가 다
만들어져 있습니다 배관들도 다 이렇게
배수로 쪽으로 연결이 되어 있고요
근데 어디선가 뭐가 잘못된 건지
아니면 누수가 있었는지 모르겠지만
바닥에 전체적으로 다 우리 고여
있고요 주차키 비트에 있는
펌프를 작동시켜줄게요
마지막에 약간 침 뱉듯이 한번
뱉었던거야 이렇게 데쳐서 이게 뭐지
하고 보니까 대단해
잡아당길 때마다 물이 삐져나오더라고요
아 이게 제대로 고정이 안 된 거죠
연결을 제대로 안 해놔서
틈새로 우리 생각하세요
물에 못 빼주고
계속
펌프가 헛돌릴 수도 있는 거죠 대수로
쭉 배관에서 물 떨어지는 거
수직으로 떨어져서
여기까지는 안 오더라구요 바닥에
고여있는 그런 상황이었어
전체적으로 문을 열면
손잡이가 벽에 닿아서
손잡이나 벽이 먹게 이제 가능성이 좀
있더라고요
여러분들도 보셨겠지만 이게 사실 당장
문제가 발생 안 하더라도 이렇게 좀
사전에 좀 체크할 수 있는 부분
체크하는게 되게 중요한 거 같아요
저희가 대형빌딩만 그렇게 관리해야
한다고 생각을 하는데 생각보다
꼬마빌딩도 이렇게 좀 세부적으로 좀
잘 관리를 해야 돼요
근데 저희가 아무래도
빌딩이 또 처음이신 분들이 대부분인데
그분들은
눈에 보이는 것만 보고 좀 이렇게
세부적으로 안 보는 경우가
대다수거든요
그러니까 더 큰 문제가 발생되기 전에
미리 좀 사전에 체크하는게 중요한 것
같습니다 저희가 약간 이벤트성으로
서울시내에 건물을 가지고 계신 분들
중에 이렇게 좀
점검을 받아보고 싶다 하시는 분은
저희
댓글에 좀 남겨 주시면 저희가 다섯
분을 선정해서 무료로
빌딩
현장 점검을 좀 해드리도록 하겠습니다
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
빌딩 관리에 관심 있으신 분들은 저희
bsn케어에 어느 정도 과장이 많이
연락 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 오늘
영상 여기까지 하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]